saluant ce moment on est en plein dans
les partielles dans le brevet dans le
bac dans les rattrapages pour certains
et je sais aussi que certains d'entre
vous n'ont pas encore commencé les
révisions bon c'est pas trop tard et on
va voir ce qu'on peut faire génériques
[Musique]
si je vous dit que vous avez été
nombreux et nombreuses à m'envoyer des
messages sur les réseaux sociaux pour
pouvoir faire des révisions de dernière
minute je serais un menteur vous a été
plus que nombreux l'année dernière à la
même période j'avais fait une vidéo un
petit peu dans ce style là je vous la
met par là je vais essayer d'en faire
une un peu plus poussé un peu plus
complémentaire est peut-être un peu plus
efficace et avant d'attaquer le vif du
sujet je vous donne deux informations
très important que le prochain live
c'est demain ce dimanche 28 à 18 heures
sur la chaîne j'ai essayé de vous
préparer des surprises est la deuxième
info c'est que vous êtes encore nombreux
à me poser des questions sur le livre il
ya une vidéo qui répond à toutes les
questions sur le livre qui est sorti et
je vous la met aussi en lien dans la
description donc dans les faits de
l'examen est en train d'approcher soit
vous avez pas réalisés soit vous êtes en
train de stressé parce que voulait
encore révisées on va partir du principe
que vous n'avez pas révisé parce que qui
peut le plus le plus avant de parler de
ce qu'il faut faire on va parler de ce
qu'il faut pas faire il ne faut pas se
noyer sous un monticule de travail ça va
rien résoudre nos problèmes et vous
allez juste d'être débordés par une
montagne de choses à apprendre
il ya cinq étapes pour réussir des
révisions de dernière minute quand on
n'a rien foutu heures et je sais de quoi
je parle
la première étape c'est la stratégie si
vous venez c'est un peu la chaîne vous
savez que je suis fan de l'art de la
guerre de sun tzu clé la stratégie c'est
toujours la première étape d'un plan
d'action que vous allez prendre une
journée complète pour poser la stratégie
et le contenu ça on va y revenir aux
comptes je sais qu'une journée c'est
long mais on n'est plus à un jour près
je crois qu'on est d'accord avec ça dans
un premier temps vous allez lister les
priorités des matières à réviser et ça
les priorités vous allez trouver avec
les coeff l'idée c'est pas de faire
l'impasse sur la petite matière mais les
matières vous êtes déjà bon les matières
à très faible qu est ce ne sont pas vos
priorités la priorité c'est les gros
coeff
vous allez donc concentrer vos efforts
sur les coeff les plus rentables en
termes de points aurait comme objectif
secondaire quand même d'avoir le minimum
syndical dans toutes les matières et oui
là le but ce n'est pas de chercher la
mention non plus dans votre stratégie
vous allez aussi établir un planning de
révisions qu'est ce que vous allez faire
des jours suivants supprimer tout ce qui
est superflu vraiment donc vous faites
un espèce d'emploi du temps pas
forcément heure par heure mais sur quoi
vous allez concentrer vos efforts jour
par jour ça ça va déjà prendre un
certain temps de cette journée vous avez
consacré à l'élaboration de votre plan
stratégique et dans cette même journée
vous allez faire appel à la deuxième
étape à savoir le contenu je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai parlé comme ça le contenu
c'est essentiel c'est ce que vous allez
devoir réviser quel formidable
découverte donc vous allez récupérer
assemblée organisée tous vos cours des
cours de vos potes si vous n'avez pas
très bien pris vaut pour les fiches que
vous pouvez avoir sur certains coups
roulés ficherait cap qu'on peut aussi
trouver sur le net peut être aussi des
livres comme des annales sur le diplôme
que vous êtes en train de passer vous
rassembler tous' savoir vous le trier
par matière et ensuite vous
triés par sous-thèmes je pense que ces
deux étapes vous prennent une matinée
complète fait une petite pause allait
manger et on va passer à ce que vous
allez faire l'après midi de cette
préparation aux révisions intensives
l'après midi vous allez créer vos outils
on va concentrer sa sur trois outils
principaux
tout d'abord des fiches de révisions
peut-être que dans votre contenu vous en
avez déjà les vôtres ou celle de
certains impôts tout celle que vous avez
trouvé sur le net
ensuite vous allez créer des maï maï de
vos cours le mind map ce sont des cartes
mentales j'en ai déjà parlé dans une
vidéo des outils pour faire ça c'est
très simple quelques feutre qui écrivent
bien qu'ils sont agréables à utiliser
c'est important à surligneurs une règle
et vous structurez votre pensée sur
votre mind maps pour faire votre carte
mentale vous allez utiliser l'imaginaire
et ça c'est génial parce que ça permet
de beaucoup mieux retenir les choses en
plus vous allez faire un travail créatif
qui va venir de vous donc ça aussi ça va
consolider savoir mais surtout pour
créer le magma vous allez obligé de
synthétiser l'information le global
peut-être pas le détail les dates par
exemple c'est de l'histoire de ce genre
de choses mais le global vous allez est
obligé de le comprendre pour pouvoir
leur verser sur le mannequin et ce sont
toutes ces choses et tout ce processus
de création des maï maï qui vont déjà
vous faire gagner un temps exceptionnel
pour réviser dans une vidéo de l'année
passée désabonnez vous m'aviez envoyez
vos propre my maps je vais vous le
maître cette vidéo là en lien dans la
description comme ça vous pourrez voir
des exemples et vous inspirer de cette
méthode est ensuite sur la fin de
journée début de soirée vous allez faire
ce qu'on appelle des flash cards là
aussi j'ai fait une vidéo sur le sujet
vous pouvez la retrouver également dans
la description avec les flashs car vous
allez pouvoir retenir des informations
très concrète une date une formule ce
genre de chose mais vous allez aussi
pouvoir mettre des petits my maps en
flash car vous allez créer de manière
recto verso je vous rappelle qu'une
flash cards ça se fait dans les deux
sens et ça peut se réaliser dans les
deux sens
un exemple bateau très concret mais je
pourrais très bien écrire sur une fiche
bristol d'un côté 21 juin de l'autre
côté fête de la musique
et si je prends la flash carte du côté
fête de la musique faut que je me
rappelle que c'est le 21 juin et si au
contraire japon du côté 21 juin faut que
je me rappelle que c'est la fête de la
musique vous voyez un petit peu le
principe
là aussi le travail de création de ces
flashs carte va vous obliger à
identifier quelles sont les choses très
important dans votre stratégie à retenir
est le fait de les créer ça va amorcer
un processus de mémorisation et là on
imagine qu'on est à la fin de cette
journée que vous avez consacré à la
préparation de votre révisions de
dernière minute vous avez vu la
stratégie le contenu vous avez les
outils il ne reste plus que la méthode à
appliquer une petite annexe la méthode
est très simple vous allez maintenant
uniquement réviser vos my maps et vos
flash cards les fiches de lecture vous
n'allez pas les réviser en tant que tel
vous allez les relire de temps en temps
car si vous avez un doute sur la
compréhension quelque chose vous relisez
les fiches de lecture que vous aviez non
on parle bien de lire pas forcément de
mémoriser les flashs carte comme vous
avez peut-être pu le voir dans mon
ancienne vidéo ça se fait en temps un
mal
par jour à la semaine au mois tous les
six mois un an et c'est là on n'a pas le
times mais là vous allez donc
fonctionner avec les flashs carte par
demi journée si vous reste six jours de
révisions vous créer 12 boîtes avec les
flash cards tout est dans la première
boîte la première matinée vous allez
faire que ça que de la flash cards que
de la flash cards est partout vous avez
bon vous mettez dans la deuxième boîte
pour l'après midi à chaque fois vous
avez bon vous passez dans la troisième
boîte qui sera pour le lendemain matin
si vous avez faut vous le laisser là
alors là je fonctionne par demi journée
c'est un peu hardcore vous pouvez aussi
fonctionner par journée c'est vous qui
voyez mais vous voyez le principe
pourrait appliquer le principe des flash
cards sur le nombre de jours qui vous
reste et pour réviser le my maps est
très simple vous essayez de le
visualiser vous voyez ce qui vous manque
vous le réalisez vous le regardez vous
re visualiser et vous vous assurez
surtout dans les mailles mal de bien
comprendre l'arborescence que vous avez
créé c'est presque terminé maintenant il
ya juste deux choses à faire qui sont
essentiels la première chose c'est de
bien dormir la compréhension la mémoire
tout passe par un cerveau en bonne forme
et pour ça il faut bien dormir faut
dormir entre 7 et 8 heures donc obligé
vous à sa fiancée et puis on sait bien
et la dernière chose et ça je pense que
c'est ce qui vous fera le plus plaisir
c'est que le fait de réviser durant des
heures est une mauvaise idée reçue si
vous voulez faire une bonne acquisition
une bonne mémorisation
je vous conseille de réviser par tranche
de 20 minutes et toutes les 20 minutes
de faire une pause de cinq minutes et
quand je dis faire une pause de cinq
minutes c'est faire une vraie pause
faire autre chose complètement choses là
vous pouvez rallumer le téléphone vous
faites ce que vous voulez mais qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec les révisions et
vous faites comme ça 20 minutes 5
minutes 20 minutes 5 minutes 20 minutes
cinq minutes c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
efficace
après peut-être que vous aussi vous
allez des techniques personnelles vous
incite à les mettre dans les
commentaires et à les partager avec tout
le monde vous pouvez vous répondre entre
vous vous donner des astuces à ce serait
top que vous puissiez vous aider dans
les révisions de dernière minute et nous
dire quels diplômes vous êtes en train
de passer tiens ça ferait comme un mini
sondage dans la vidéo et puis j'espère
sincèrement que ça vous aidera et que
vous viendrez nous dire si vous avez eu
votre diplôme ou pas partager cette
vidéo personnes que ça pourrait aider
n'oubliez pas de lire et de vous abonner
rendez vous très bientôt donc demain à
18 heures pour ceux qui seront là au
live ciao